let's bring in Ari Fleischer he's a Fox
News contributor and former White House
press secretary for President George W
Bush Ari on the question about you when
you get the United Nations and the World
Health Organization involved I mean
there is a lot of skepticism across
America when it comes to these
organizations warranted in this case yes
and no look this is a classic babies in
bath water style issue there's a lot
that the WH doe does in rural countries
in poor countries around the world that
is very helpful when it comes to the
work in the more sophisticated modern
countries it's not as influential or
helpful but we do know as they made two
fundamental errors with China one they
acknowledge they just passed a law
Chinese statement saying there's no
human to human transmission of
coronavirus in late January mid January
and then they also criticized the United
States for shutting down flights from
China both of those were errors in
judgment or just errors they deserve
criticism for that and I funding is
something that the United States we fund
a lot of things across the world and we
usually do more of our lion's share I
mean one thing that you could see is
should the United States have more of a
say in the organization if we're going
to keep funding it absolutely this has
been an American International weakness
going back for decades we fund so many
international organizations way beyond
what any other nation does and those
nations often use our money to kick us
to criticize us and we seem to roll over
and take it so um look when this is over
Dana one of the things we have to do is
have a second look at a lot of different
institutions not to pull it a size but
to say what could be done better and
that includes the w-h-o and includes the
CDC it includes the FDA there's a whole
lot that we have to learn from this to
do better and the w-h-o has got to be
open and accessible to tell what we
they've done and not call it
politicization and try to get out of it
by dismissing it politicization is the
worst word I wish we had a different
word for it because it bothers me that
word I can't ever say it correctly but
you did you said it just right talk
about politics I do want to move to this
because today Bernie Sanders decide
okay he's gonna call it quits but he did
say that he wants to remain on those
ballots and so so that he can continue
to accumulate delegates so that he can
have some influence over the DNC
convention your thoughts well the
influence he said he wants is on the
platform committee and I'm submit to you
he already has had tremendous influence
on the Biden Committee he has moved Joe
Biden so far to the left
positions that Joe Biden used to fight
against he now fights for because of
Bernie Sanders he wants a public option
on health care on government-run health
care he was opposed to that when he was
Barack Obama's vice president he now
wants a green new deal he wants free
college he doesn't want to deport any
illegal immigrants who committed
felonies all of these are positions on
the far far left of the Democratic Party
brought to you
sponsored by Bernie Sanders now proudly
adopted by Joe Biden right right his
movement did have some impact I'm
wondering about this so former President
Obama had set it out he said he probably
wouldn't comment until this was all over
and now that Biden is the presumptive
nominee is do you expect to see
President Obama maybe weigh-in now
yeah absolutely I don't know about
immediately now but it would I expect
would happen if it was a normal year and
you could travel would be a gigantic
Obama Biden event a huge celebration
Bernie might be there as well Elizabeth
Warren and they hold hands and have a
unified appearance that's coming we just
don't know what day will they create it
virtually will they do it in person it's
coming it'll be it'll be a really big
zoom if they decide to do that because
it's not gonna happen anytime soon as
people can't get together all right
ari fleischer thank you so much